oh no it's falling oh alright y'all the
holidays are almost here and I'm getting
into the spirit by decorating a
gingerbread house hmm
but since the internet is super weird we
obviously know we can't do things the
normal way so I'm going to challenge
myself to decorate this gingerbread
house with what's in the big box what
shall it be tiny hands okay it's the
tiny hand challenge the internet is
weird y'all it's weird but let's do this
my tiny hands my decorating strategy
well I'm basically just gonna nail it
apparently oh my god my clothes are all
in it it's fine dry cleaning my index
fingers hurts so bad oh my god
one down let's do this one okay wait I'm
gonna let you see what I'm doing
I've got really strong index fingers is
what I'm finding out but I need a break
okay this is so hard is it does it look
okay yes it's so hard my I'm like trying
to like okay wait oh you got to use the
other fingers on the tiny hands is it oh
I didn't know that
well you can't oh yeah you can't do that
no you can do it on my show well wait
let me switch fingers my index fingers
are killing me
I need like sparkle oh my gosh how do
you okay wait I hate the internet I feel
so accomplished yeah let's concentrate
wait let's do another one oh my gosh
let's see if we can do a pearl or
whatever this is oh okay man down okay
let me just scoop it oh look look what I
got it I got it
look it's sticking to it though right I
mean it's kind of messy but look at it
on it's stuck to it I'm clever
oh snap is that what this is okay uh you
can suck it you knew how he's gonna
happen I mean in the big the big guns
get out you have to need it okay get out
of my way okay there's something
seriously therapeutic about this I'm
just saying does this kind of squishy oh
my God look what I'm doing you all I did
this on accident but is it an accident I
think not
I'm making a heart I didn't even mean to
wait for it okay you said blue people
he's like glue let me need that out that
looks sad a bit okay this is gonna be
special it's a heart come on
home is where the heart is
it's beautiful Oh oops oh whoops Oh
bleep oh my god get out of my house okay
oh okay
hey you don't you know you don't want to
play it's fine okay how'd I do that
before it's like magic oh my gosh I'm
sweating this is like give me a minute
I'm getting this dang thing yeah oh no
it's falling it's like so hard all the
pull in switching switching fingers
we're going back to index people or
going back to index
okay it's gonna be fantastic you know
why because in frozen the heart is it's
it's something about frozen that warms
up right or something I don't have
anything poetic there but you know oh
look we forgot these like wait mm-hmm oh
it's cute on the back that's the thing
that's the thing hold on wait hold on
wait oh I didn't mean to do that
okay wait yes tiny hands yes okay wait
okay wait oh shoot
okay okay that's pretty late right a
picture that note take a picture now I
feel like I pretty much nailed it
because it's really difficult and funny
and my fingers hurt I'm gonna get myself
a round of applause thank you thank you
bye I love you America
bye world I don't know why I said
America the Internet's like worldwide so
I love you world bye
[Music]
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this